[Music]
decided to split from the rest of the
mainly palestinian-israeli joint list
alliance
and campaign separately it was a big
gamble that earned him plenty of
blowback
now with five seats in the israeli
parliament his united arab list
in theory has the power to bestow either
side a majority
get out and vote so he can be king
makers in the elections
we need to succeed so we can establish
our status and our
influence in politics for the future of
the next generation
abbas politics are religious and
conservative right-wing israeli
politicians call him anti-zionist
left-wingers criticize his stance on
lgbtq issues
and yet his openness to engage with and
potentially support
either the block led by prime minister
benjamin netanyahu
or the one trying to remove netanyahu
from power has shaken up israeli
politics
[Music]
during the campaign netanyahu ruled out
the idea of allowing abbas into his
coalition
or even accepting his support from the
outside but that was before his bloc
once again fell short of the 61 seats it
needed
and senior members of his party started
openly discussing
working with abbas for some even having
such a conversation
represents a political watershed the
very engagement
between the two particularly to the
extent that it will be public
is going to be historic and the
transformative for israeli politics
and from that point of view it could
have results and outcome
irrespective of whether it actually
reaches a new coalition agreement
abbas isn't the only one celebrating the
prospects of influence in the new
parliament
the far-right religious zionism movement
also outperformed expectations
and would be welcomed in a netanyahu
coalition
[Music]
a buses party says it won't sit with
racists
the opposition leader yan lapid also
says a government relying
on religious zionism would be dark and
dangerous
but marshalling his own coalition with
support from arab politicians
would also be a difficult sell to the
right wingers in the anti-netanyahu bloc
not every path to a government runs
through mansur abbas for instance
netanyahu could try to
poach off a right-wing politician or two
from another party
lapid less likely could try to break off
part of the netanyahu bloc
and there's still a possibility of total
failure and a fifth
election to come but after four
elections
this is a very different type of
political conversation with the
palestinian-israeli party
at its center harry fawcett al-jazeera
west jerusalem